The House of the Dragon TV show very
closely follows George R.R Martin's Fire
and Blood novel but there are still
differences between the show and the
book since there's not enough time in
this video to go through every change
that they've made I've gone and found
the 10 craziest differences between the
house of the Dragon TV show and the book
there will obviously be spoilers so
don't watch this video If you're not
fully caught up
[Music]
number 10 Laris Strong's murders in the
house of the Dragon TV series Lara
strong is shown to be the one to
instigate the great fire at harrenhal
that killed both Lord Lionel strong his
father and Sir Harwin strong his brother
he did so by setting three prisoners
free cutting out their tongue so they
couldn't speak about what lairs told
them to do and having them set fire to
his family's room at harrenhal in the
book however the fire was blamed on the
curse of harrenhal although maesters and
historians suspected other culprits for
the fire including Prince Damon
Targaryen Lord Corliss valerion King
viserys Targaryen and also Lara strong
this change makes a significant impact
on the story at large changing
everything we know about Laris and his
willingness to do whatever it takes to
climb his way up in westerosi society
although it's not explicitly shown that
he intended to have his family murdered
so the question arises did Laris kill
his father and brother number nine
Damon's first wife Damon targaryen's
first wife and the heir to runestone
Lady Raya Royce was shown to have been
killed or helped to die by Damon and
House of the Dragon when she fell from
her horse and Damon finished her off
with a rock it was shown that he had
come to runestone to claim his place as
the local Lord but in the book Fire and
Blood lady Royce was already the ruling
Lady of runestone and Damon was fighting
in the stepstones when she died so
instead of being killed by Damon it was
written that she died when she fell from
her horse while hunting in the veil he
later flew to runestone on his Dragon
character's when he heard of her death
to make his claim for the ruling seat at
runestone which he was denied the change
in story to demon killing his wife who
he called the bronze [ __ ] really shows
Demon's character and his distaste for
anyone not of Targaryen or Valyrian
ancestry number eight fact versus
fiction one of the most significant
differences between House of the dragon
and fire and blood is that the series is
shown as an official account of the
events leading up to the dance of the
Dragons while the book is a collection
of second-hand stories which may not be
entirely factual Author George R.R
Martin wrote Fire and Blood as an
in-world history book by archmaester
gildane who wrote the book long after
the events of the dance of the dragons
in this this history book gildane uses
several different sources to write the
stories including accounts from septon
Eustis Grand maester Monken and the
court fool mushroom so the team working
on House of the dragon have had to adapt
the stories from somewhat biased sources
which a lot of the time each provides a
differing account of what happened
number seven eamon's eye House of the
Dragon gave us an absolutely stunning
scene where Eamon first bonded with the
titanic-sized dragon vegar afterward
we're shown a scene where rhaenira's son
luceris cuts out eamon's left eye
leading to Allison calling for one of
lucerus's eyes in Revenge although Eamon
says losing an eye was worth gaining a
dragon this scene differs in the book
however as Bayland Reyna Targaryen
weren't present Luke only cut out
eamon's eye after calling him and Jace
strongs and it was actually his right
eye that got cut out not as left number
six Lena's death in house of the Dragon
were shown Lena valerion in labor and
the maesters tell Eamon that they're
unable to get the child to be born
naturally Lena overhearing this decides
she does not want to die in childbirth
and instead wants to die a dragon
Rider's death so she walked out to her
dragon vegar and commanded it to breathe
fire on her shouting dracaryus and the
dragon obliged burning her alive in Fire
and Blood however Lena did give birth to
a son but he only survived for an hour
Lena's Health soon began to deteriorate
and three days after the delivery she
left her bed to try to fly on vegar one
last time but collapsed and died on her
way there this retelling of Lena's death
gives a much more powerful story for her
character showing her as a proud Dragon
Rider with the blood of old valyria
pulsing through her veins quick plug if
you like what you're seeing hit that
subscribe button for more videos like
this now back to the video number five
rhaenyra and Allison most of the scenes
early on in the show where Rainier and
Alice spend time together as friends
never really happened in the book in
fact Rainier and Allison weren't ever
true friends as Allison was nine years
older than Rainier in Fire and Blood in
House of the Dragon however they're
depicted as great childhood friends
spending lots of time together in the
godswood and the fact that they were
close friends as children places even
more tension on their relationship when
Allison Mary's Ray near his father
viserys in the book though they really
don't even have a relationship until
Allison marries viserys before then they
likely knew of each other but hardly
spoke to one another I think this change
from the book was really great creating
scenes with a lot more drama and higher
Stakes at hand number 4. lenor's Death
In The House of the Dragon series we saw
rhaenyra and her husband Lenor valerion
at a point in their sham marriage where
Rainier wanted to move on to unite
herself with her Uncle Damon gross and
Lenor wanted to run away from his
problems with his lover sir Carl Corey
the series shows us how demon offered
Carl and Leonor the opportunity to run
away together across the narrow Sea by
staging a fight and faking leanor's
death they do so as opposed to the book
Fire and Blood where Carl actually kills
laner for money leaving Leonard's Dragon
sea smoke riderless this was likely done
in the show because without Damon giving
laner the option to run away he'd simply
be seen as a bloodthirsty murderer doing
whatever it takes to marry his niece
including paying someone to kill her
husband number three aegon's visions one
of the driving factors behind the first
season of House of the Dragon was
visiris's insistence upon passing on the
details of aegon the conqueror's vision
of the end of times where one Targaryen
would have to unite all the Realms of
men to fight against a great winter in
the darkness that comes with it a vision
he called A Song of Ice and Fire but it
was never actually mentioned in the book
and neither were any of the Targaryen
dreams besides Danish the dreamer's
vision about the Doom of valyria it was
aegon's dream of the great winter that
pushed him to conquer and unite the
Seven Kingdoms giving a much more
in-depth backstory as to the reasoning
for why aegon was so relentless in his
Conquest although it was never fully
mentioned in the book it was George RR
Martin's idea to include this plotline
about Visions so he could still tie it
in with the storylines and the books
later on number two vaman's death the
ninth episode of House of the Dragon
gave us the death of Lord cordless
valerian's brother vaman valerion when
he was beheaded by Daemon Targaryen and
the red keep when Corliss was injured in
a battle in the stepstones vaman made
the claim that he was the true heir to
driftmark because rhaenya and leaner's
children were bastards but he went a bit
too far calling Rainier is some
expletive terms and dismissing her claim
to the Iron Throne so viserys called for
his tongue and immediately Damon instead
cut his head in half saying he could
keep his tongue in the book Fire and
Blood however the events happened quite
differently instead of being injured in
battle Lord Corliss Valerian became sick
and the question of who might take his
place on the driftmark throne arose
rhaenyra urged for his son Luke to be
named as the heir to driftmark as her
firstborn son Jace would be heir to the
Iron Throne after her vehmond still in
driftmark stated that her children were
bastards and had no claim to driftmark
outraged by this Rainier had her husband
Damon fly to driftmark where he beheaded
vemond and brought the head back to
Rainier which she fed to her Dragon
Cyrax while I do think it would have
been cool to see Rainier and Damon use
their dragons a bit more feeding their
enemies heads to the beasts I understand
why this change was made probably for
budgetary reasons also without this
change we wouldn't have gotten the
amazing scene where the old and sickly
viserys arrives in the red keep like a
bat to stand up for his daughter and
grandsons number one rainys in the
dragon pit episode 9 of House of the
Dragon also gave us a really intense
scene where princess rhaenice the queen
that never was burst through the floor
of the Dragon pit on her Dragon melees
killing hundreds of civilians in King's
Landing before she comes face to face
with Queen Allison and the newly crowned
King aegon II she decides to fly away
rather than burn them to a crisp which
would have stopped all the mounting
tensions leading up to the impending
Civil War but none of this happened in
the book rhaenys didn't destroy the
dragon pit floor she didn't kill
hundreds of innocent people and she
never had the chance to burn Allison and
her children and one fell swoop in Fire
and Blood she was already back at
driftmark when aegon was crowned as king
at this point in time I think this might
be one of the biggest and one of the
most unnecessary changes made so far I
don't feel like it added much to
rhaenys's character because her actions
are just so contradictory on one hand
she's willing to kill hundreds of
civilians to get her Dragon but on the
other she's not willing to kill the
usurpus for the throne to put a stop to
the Civil War that will kill thousands
it just doesn't really make sense I get
that the writers wanted an epic
conclusion leading up to the season
finale but it feels like this scene
definitely could have been done
differently but I'd like to know what
you think which changes do you like the
most and the least drop your thoughts in
the comment section below also check out
the video on your screen for some more
of my content don't forget to like And
subscribe and thanks for watching Rocket
Riley
foreign